From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. OK, here is something that we did not expect. Check this out. This was recorded on a stage in Brooklyn, St. Francis College.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。好的，这里有一件我们意想不到的事情。看看这个。这是在布鲁克林圣弗朗西斯学院的舞台上录制的。
To be or not to be, that is the question.
生存还是毁灭，这是一个值得考虑的问题。
Same month in Hawaii, on the island of Oahu.
同一个月在夏威夷，瓦胡岛上。
To be or not to be, that is the question-- whether 'tis nobler in the mind to suffer the slings and arrows of outrageous fortune or to take arms against a sea of troubles and by opposing, end them.
生存还是毁灭，这是一个值得考虑的问题——究竟哪种更高贵：是忍受狂暴命运的毒箭，还是挺身反抗无边的苦难，通过斗争结束它们。
Same month, a professional company in Boston, Massachusetts, at the Public Theater.
同一个月，马萨诸塞州波士顿的一家专业剧团，在公共剧院。
Whether 'tis nobler in the mind to suffer the slings and arrows of outrageous fortune or to take arms against a sea of troubles and by opposing, end them.
究竟哪种更高贵：是忍受狂暴命运的毒箭，还是挺身反抗无边的苦难，通过斗争结束它们。
In Colorado, at Camp Shakespeare, you can actually hear the sneakers of the teenaged Hamlet squeaking.
在科罗拉多州的莎士比亚训练营，你甚至能听到十几岁的哈姆雷特扮演者运动鞋发出的吱吱声。
[SNEAKERS SQUEAKING]
[运动鞋摩擦声]
Why do you go about to recover the wind of me?
你为什么要试图窥探我的心思？
Oh my lord, if my duty be too bold--
哦，大人，如果我的忠诚过于唐突——
And at the Bay Area Shakespeare Camp, presented by the San Francisco Shakespeare Festival, the kids put on a production that they have concocted that is made up entirely of death scenes from different Shakespeare plays. That seems because, um, kids love death scenes.
在旧金山莎士比亚节举办的湾区莎士比亚夏令营里，孩子们自编自导了一出戏，完全由莎士比亚不同剧作中的死亡场景组成。这似乎是因为，嗯，孩子们喜欢死亡场景。
No, no! The drink, the drink! O, my dear Hamlet, the drink, the drink! I am poisoned! [GAGGING]
不，不！那杯酒，那杯酒！哦，亲爱的哈姆雷特，那杯酒，那杯酒！我中毒了！[呕吐声]
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
[观众笑声]
Eight-year-old Marissa Graham grabs her throat like a cat in a violent cartoon. Everyone in the production is eight, except for Polonius, who's six.
八岁的玛丽莎·格雷厄姆像暴力卡通片里的猫一样抓住喉咙。剧组里每个人都是八岁，除了饰演波洛尼厄斯的那个孩子，他只有六岁。
The rest is silence.
余下的只有沉默。
[AUDIENCE CHUCKLING, APPLAUDING]
[观众笑声、掌声]
There's actually no way to tell how many productions of Hamlet are up in any given month. In summer 2002, when we first broadcast today's show and when we made these recordings, the American Theatre website listed 12 theaters doing Shakespeare's Hamlet, 11 productions of the play I Hate Hamlet, one production of something called Hamlet Dreams, and one theater doing the dreadful and feared Hamletmachine.
事实上，无法统计在任何一个月里有多少场《哈姆雷特》正在上演。2002年夏天，当我们首次播出今天的节目并进行这些录音时，美国戏剧网站列出了12家正在排演莎士比亚《哈姆雷特》的剧院，11场名为《我恨哈姆雷特》的演出，一场名为《哈姆雷特之梦》的演出，还有一家剧院正在排演那部可怕而令人恐惧的《哈姆雷特机器》。
Of course, Hamlet itself is kind of a weird play. The central character is in a situation that very few of us are ever going to find ourselves in. His uncle killed his father and then married his mother in order to become the king. The play is four hours long. The main conflict of the play is a guy debating, in long, complicated monologues, whether or not he should kill somebody. What is there in that for most of us to relate to?
当然，《哈姆雷特》本身是一部奇怪的剧。主角所处的境地是我们大多数人永远不会遇到的。他的叔叔杀了他父亲，然后娶了他母亲，只为了成为国王。这部剧长达四个小时。剧中的主要矛盾是一个男人在冗长而复杂的独白中纠结是否应该杀人。这对我们大多数人来说有什么共鸣之处呢？
Unless, of course, we happen to be murderers. And what would the play be like if it were actually performed by murderers and other violent criminals? What would they see that the rest of us do not?
除非我们刚好是杀人犯。如果这出戏真的由杀人犯和其他暴力罪犯来表演会是什么样？他们会看到什么我们看不到的东西呢？
Well, today on our program we answer that question. And the answer is, a lot. Over the course of six months, reporter Jack Hitt visited prisoners at the Missouri Eastern Correctional Center-- which is a high-security prison-- from their first rehearsal to their last performance of Act V of Shakespeare's Hamlet. We're devoting our entire program today to the drama that he found there. Our program today, "Act V." We bring you what we believe is one of the most evocative productions of Shakespeare done anywhere in 2002, one you would have had a hard time getting tickets to-- it was only performed in prison. Here's Jack Hitt.
嗯，今天我们的节目将回答这个问题。答案是，有很多。在六个月的时间里，记者杰克·希特访问了密苏里州东部惩教中心的囚犯——这是一所高度安全监狱——从他们的第一次排练到最后演出莎士比亚《哈姆雷特》第五幕。我们今天将整期节目奉献给他在那里发现的戏剧。我们今天的节目名为“第五幕”。我们为您带来我们认为2002年任何地方演出的最令人回味的莎士比亚剧作之一，你可能很难买到票，因为它只在监狱里演出。下面是杰克·希特。
The first thing they hand me when I pass through the thick iron doors is a tiny black box called a screamer. Pull the cord attached, and a phalanx of armed guards will sweep from all points of the prison and try to rescue me. I keep it in my pocket as I enter a huge yard with more than 1,000 prisoners wandering around. Some of the guys are playing handball against walls, some are lifting weights as I walk across, most are friendly. A couple of the skinheads, their arms dense with spider tattoos, narrow their eyes as I pass.
当我穿过厚重的铁门时，他们给我的第一样东西是一个被称为“尖叫器”的小黑盒。拉动附带的绳子，一队武装警卫会从监狱的四面八方涌来试图营救我。我把它放在口袋里，走进了一个有超过1000名囚犯漫步其中的巨大庭院。有些人在对着墙打手球，有些人正在举重。当我走过时，大多数人很友好。几个手臂上布满蜘蛛纹身的光头党在我经过时眯起了眼睛。
Across the yard, there's a big building. A long corridor leads to a door marked Education Annex. Inside, there's room D-168, where a small, white-haired woman, Agnes Wilcox, is holding auditions for Hamlet.
院子对面有一座大楼。一条长长的走廊通向一扇标有“教育附件”的门。里面是D-168室，一位留着白发的矮小女性艾格尼丝·威尔科克斯正在为《哈姆雷特》选角。
Let me see. If you're not Hamlet, Horatio, Laertes, Claudius, or Fortinbras, would you write down roles that interest you? Those roles are Clown 1 and 2, we've got Priest, we've got Osric.
让我看看。如果你不是哈姆雷特、霍拉旭、雷欧提斯、克劳狄斯或福丁布拉，请写下你感兴趣的角色。那些角色是小丑1和2，还有牧师，还有奥斯里克。
Dressed in loose prison uniforms, the actors sit around tables in the cinder block classroom beneath inspirational slogans-- believe in yourself, think positively. The aspiring cast is half black, half white, and ranges from young lifers in their 20s to old timers in their 50s. Because it's against the rules to congregate an audience of felons for the four hours it would take to perform the whole play, Agnes has staged one act every six months, starting in December, 1999. Tonight is the first read through for Act V, the final bloody climax. Many of the inmates here never finished high school, and all they had known of Shakespeare was the phrase "To be or not to be." Tonight they are hearing some of the other famous speeches for the first time.
穿着宽松的囚服，演员们坐在 cinder block 教室的桌子旁，墙上挂着鼓舞人心的标语——相信自己，积极思考。这些有抱负的演员有一半是黑人，一半是白人，年龄从二十多岁的年轻无期徒刑犯到五十多岁的老资历都有。因为规定禁止为演出整部戏所需的四个小时聚集大批囚犯，艾格尼丝从1999年12月开始，每六个月排演一幕。今晚是第五幕的第一次剧本研读，这是最后的血腥高潮。这里的许多囚犯从未读完高中，他们对莎士比亚唯一的了解就是那句“生存还是毁灭”。今晚他们第一次听到了其他一些著名的演讲。
A pestilence on him, for a mad rouge.
对他这个疯子施加天谴。
Rogue.
无赖。
Rogue. He poured a flax--
无赖。他曾经把一瓶——
Flagon.
酒壶。
Flagon of--
一壶——
Rhenish.
莱茵酒。
Rhenish on my head once. This same skull, sir, was sure Yorick's skull, the king's jester.
莱茵酒泼在我的头上。先生，这个头骨，确实是约里克的头骨，也就是国王的弄臣。
Alas, poor Yorick. I knew him, Horatio. A fellow of infinite jest, of most excellent fancy. He hath bore me on his back 1,000 times--
唉，可怜的约里克。我认识他，霍拉旭。一个有着无穷诙谐和绝佳想象力的家伙。他曾一千次把我背在背上——
Most read-throughs with any cast are terrible. This one is terrible too. The actors know it. But they plow on through the script. An inmate named Paul, who serves as Agnes' assistant director, explains why.
大多数剧组的第一次剧本研读都很糟糕。这次也不例外。演员们自己也知道。但他们还是坚持读完了剧本。一位名叫保罗的囚犯，担任艾格尼丝的助理导演，解释了原因。
The first two or three acts I thought, oh no, there's no way. There's no way we're going to get this thing down and go and do a live performance and-- doing a soliloquy that's two pages long, I thought there's-- no, no. This is impossible. But what we're learning here, I guess, from performing it and hearing it done time again, was the "It'll be OK. It'll work out."
前两三幕时我想，哦不，不可能。我们不可能掌握这个并进行现场演出，还要表演两页长的独白，我想这——不，不。这太不可能了。但我想我们在这里从一遍又一遍的表演和聆听中学到的是，“没事的，会好起来的。”
The local critics agreed with Paul. The Act IV performance earned a review in the St. Louis paper. The actors were said to be commanding and compelling. With the entire performance, the reviewer wrote, "A 400-year-old text is restored to freshness." It seemed hard to imagine.
当地的评论家同意保罗的看法。第四幕的演出在圣路易斯的报纸上获得了评论。演员们被评价为气场强大且引人入胜。评论家写道，通过这次完整的演出，“一部400年前的文本焕发了新生。”这似乎很难想象。
I've seen Hamlet a dozen times. I've seen Kevin Kline do it at the Public Theater. I saw the famous Diane Venora version three nights in a row. I even saw Ingmar Bergman's production done in Brooklyn, performed entirely in Swedish. What else is there to learn from watching another Hamlet?
我看过十几遍《哈姆雷特》。我见过凯文·克莱恩在公共剧院的演出。我连续三个晚上看过著名的戴安·薇诺拉版本。我甚至看过英格玛·伯格曼在布鲁克林制作、全瑞典语表演的版本。通过看另一场《哈姆雷特》还能学到什么呢？
But the truth is, this production was different. Because this is a play about a man pondering a violent crime and its consequences performed by violent criminals living out those consequences. After hanging out with this group of convicted actors for six months, I did discover something. I didn't know anything about Hamlet.
但事实是，这次演出与众不同。因为这是一部关于一个男人思考暴力犯罪及其后果的戏，由正在亲身经历这些后果的暴力罪犯表演。在与这群被定罪的演员相处了六个月后，我确实发现了一些事情。我以前对《哈姆雷特》一无所知。
Remember how it starts. Hamlet sees his father's ghost, who explains he was murdered by Claudius, Hamlet's uncle. The ghost commands Hamlet to avenge his death by killing Claudius. The play is basically Hamlet pondering this single horrific action, and whether he can be the man to do it. "To be or not to be."
记得它是怎么开始的吗？哈姆雷特见到了他父亲的鬼魂，鬼魂解释说他被叔叔克劳狄斯谋杀了。鬼魂命令哈姆雷特通过杀死克劳狄斯来复仇。这出戏本质上就是哈姆雷特在思考这个极其可怕的行为，以及他是否能成为那个动手的人。“生存还是毁灭。”
These days, when people say the name Hamlet, it's usually just a metaphor, shorthand for somebody who is afraid to act, who dithers and thinks too much. We almost forget just what action Hamlet was contemplating. These actors haven't forgotten.
这些天，当人们提到“哈姆雷特”这个名字时，它通常只是一个隐喻，是那些不敢行动、犹豫不决、想得太多的人的缩写。我们几乎忘记了哈姆雷特究竟在考虑什么行动。而这些演员没有忘记。
My name is Manuel Johnson, and I'm 36 years old. I'm here for two first degree assaults. I play Hamlet.
我叫曼努埃尔·约翰逊，今年36岁。我因两项一级袭击罪入狱。我饰演哈姆雷特。
When you're onstage doing Hamlet, what do you draw upon in your own experience to make the character come to life?
当你在台上表演哈姆雷特时，你从自己的经历中汲取了什么来让这个角色栩栩如生？
The idea of wanting to hurt someone. I have experience hurting someone-- you know, to the point of their life may be in danger. I was a very confused and angry person. And you know, it escalated into, you know, me shooting two people and leaving them for dead.
想要伤害别人的想法。我有伤害人的经历——你知道，到了生命可能处于危险的地步。我当时是一个非常困惑和愤怒的人。你知道，这升级为我射击了两个人，并把他们丢在那里等死。
My name is Chris Harris. I'm 38 years old. And I play the fourth character of Hamlet.
我叫克里斯·哈里斯。今年38岁。我扮演哈姆雷特的四个角色之一。
Let me explain something. The character of Hamlet is played by four people. They are all on stage at the same time, taking turns delivering the lines. Agnes did this partly to give more actors speaking roles and not saddle any one man with all that dialogue. But as theatre, it works. Hamlet's role is full of long soliloquies and rhetorical asides. This small gang of Hamlets, which mutters to itself and laughs at its own jokes, nicely captures that fractured quality of Hamlet's different personalities. And it's also bonded the four actors together. They call themselves "The Hamlets" and constantly talk about their character. To Chris, it seems like Hamlet is just the fifth guy in their odd clique-- another criminal with a complicated past.
让我解释一下。哈姆雷特的角色由四个人共同担任。他们同时在台上，轮流说台词。艾格尼丝这样做部分是为了让更多的演员有发言权，而不让任何一个人负担所有的台词。但作为戏剧，它奏效了。哈姆雷特的角色充满了长篇独白和反讽的旁白。这一小群哈姆雷特，对自己嘀咕、嘲笑自己的笑话，恰如其分地捕捉到了哈姆雷特人格分裂的特质。这也将这四位演员紧密地联系在一起。他们称自己为“哈姆雷特们”，并不断讨论他们的角色。对克里斯来说，哈姆雷特就像他们这个奇怪小圈子里的第五个人——另一个有着复杂过去的罪犯。
Let me put it in terms of the year 2000s. What we have is an upper-middle class youngster, 19, 20 years old, who comes from a well-to-do family. You know, they own quite a bit of land. The people in the small town respect him and love him. And his uncle murdered his father and is now married to his mother. So, I mean, all kinds of serious issues there, all kinds.
让我用2000年代的说法来解释。我们拥有的是一个来自富有家庭、19、20岁的上中产阶级年轻人。你知道，他们拥有相当多的土地。小镇上的人尊重他、爱戴他。他的叔叔杀了他父亲，现在娶了他母亲。所以，我的意思是，这其中有各种严重的矛盾，各种各样。
Chris and the Hamlets practice alone most days. Finding time when the four can just get together by themselves is tough when there's always 1,000 inmates around. So they do it where they can.
克里斯和“哈姆雷特们”大多数日子里独自练习。当周围总有1000名囚犯时，找到四个人能聚在一起的时间很困难。所以他们在力所能及的地方排练。
On every Sunday after the noon meal, the four of us will assemble. We'll have our little gray Hamlet books, and we'll proceed down to the track. And if you were simply walking by, what you'd probably hear is-- you'd hear this chatter of somebody giving their lines clearly, the rest of us with our heads down in the books, walking the line.
每个周日午餐后，我们四个人就会集合。我们拿着我们的小灰色《哈姆雷特》书，沿着轨道走。如果你只是路过，你可能会听到的是——你会听到有人清晰地背诵台词的喋喋不休，我们其余人低着头看书，沿着线走。
Now, there are people-- because there are benches that are all throughout the inside of the track. So there are people that actually watch us. So you'll hear this old English-style speech. You know, "Ho, Horatio," and these people are like, "Ho, what"?
现在，轨道内侧到处都是长凳。所以实际上有人在看我们。所以你会听到这种古英语风格的演讲。你知道，“嘿，霍拉旭，”而这些人会说，“嘿，什么？”
One of the problems of doing any play in prison is that being a good actor is the exact emotional opposite of what it takes to be a successful inmate. Rather than close off all feeling and look tough, you have to open your vulnerable self up and withstand often cruel laughter as you try to find some authentic emotion within you. In this way, a level-four high-security prison is no different from high school. And so most of the inmates who audition for Agnes tend to be, you know, actor-y people-- the theatre-types of prison. Back in 1999, they just had to put up with abuse from the bigger, meaner inmates. But that changed. In fact, a lot changed, after Agnes cast the role of Hamlet's best friend.
在监狱里排演任何戏剧的一个问题是，做一个好演员与做一个成功的囚犯在情感上是截然相反的。与其封闭所有感觉、表现得强硬，你必须敞开脆弱的自我，忍受常常残酷的嘲笑，试图在内心找到某种真实的情感。从这个意义上讲，四级高度安全监狱与高中没什么不同。所以大多数报名参加艾格尼丝选角的囚犯往往是，你知道，那种有表演欲的人——监狱里的戏剧类型。早在1999年，他们还得忍受更强壮、更刻薄的囚犯的虐待。但情况改变了。事实上，在艾格尼丝选定哈姆雷特最好的朋友这个角色后，很多事情都改变了。
My name is Derrick, Big Hutch. I just-- I play Horatio, the scholar.
我叫德里克，“大哈奇”。我——我扮演霍拉旭，那个学者。
You might be surprised to learn that Derrick "Big Hutch" Hutchison is big. He has a smooth, bald skull and hooded threatening eyes-- the kind of guy that if you met him, you might think, he's probably serving 120 years for armed robberies. And that would be correct. Hutch isn't like the rest of the cast, and he's the first person to tell you.
你可能会惊讶地发现德里克·“大哈奇”·哈奇森个头很大。他有着光滑的秃顶和充满威胁感的深陷眼窝——那种如果你见到他，可能会认为他因为武装抢劫被判了120年刑的人。你是对的。哈奇和其他演员不一样，他是第一个告诉你这一点的人。
In prison, you got this hierarchy system. Listen, let's compare it to the ocean. You've got the minnows, and you've got the killer whale. Minnow being the lowest, killer whale the highest.
在监狱里，你有这种等级制度。听着，让我们把它比作海洋。你有小鱼，你有虎鲸。小鱼是最低级的，虎鲸是最高级的。
So, which are you, Big Hutch?
那么，你是哪种，大哈奇？
I'm the blue whale.
我是蓝鲸。
[CHUCKLING] Right.
[笑声]对。
That mean I control the killer whales, and I can eat up the minnows if I want. And I mean, that's how it is. Most of the guys in Hamlet, they're minnows. I mean, I don't normally would associate with them.
这意味着我控制虎鲸，如果我想，我可以吃掉小鱼。我的意思是，事实就是这样。哈姆雷特剧组里的大多数人，他们是小鱼。我的意思是，我通常不会和他们交往。
Well, as he puts it, the killer whale versus the guppies, we're all guppies and he's the killer whale--
嗯，正如他所说，虎鲸对阵孔雀鱼，我们都是孔雀鱼，而他是虎鲸——
That's Tim, who plays Osric. And as a minnow/guppy, his take is a little different.
那是扮演奥斯里克的蒂姆。作为一个小鱼/孔雀鱼，他的看法略有不同。
In dealing with an individual like a killer whale, a lot of it-- a lot of, even for him, is a lot of show. The guys see him out in the yard, all right. And now some of the guys that have come into Hamlet, seeing how he is in acting and the seriousness that he takes, he's not what his persona is.
在与像虎鲸这样的人打交道时，很多——对他来说，很多也是表演。大家在院子里看到他，好的。现在一些加入《哈姆雷特》的人看到他在表演中的样子以及他对待这件事的认真程度，他并不是那种他平时表现出来的样子。
In other words, he's an actor. But Big Hutch is also a critic. His criticism is sharp and extends to places most actors avoid-- his own character, Horatio.
换句话说，他是个演员。但大哈奇也是个评论家。他的批评非常尖锐，延伸到大多数演员会避免的地方——他自己的角色，霍拉旭。
I think he a chump, for real.
我觉得他是个笨蛋，真的。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah, I think he a chump. I mean, he supposed to be cool with Hamlet. And they're best friends. But I think Horatio is just somebody-- a sounding board for Hamlet. I mean, the majority of his lines is, eh, my lord, yes, my lord. I mean, if we're friends, we're going to communicate better than that. I mean, you're going to tell me your deepest secrets. So I want to know what you and Ophelia did last night.
是啊，我觉得他是个笨蛋。我的意思是，他应该是哈姆雷特的好哥们。他们是最好的朋友。但我觉得霍拉旭只是某个人——哈姆雷特的传声筒。我的意思是，他大部分的台词就是，嗯，大人，是的，大人。我的意思是，如果我们是朋友，我们会沟通得比这更好。我的意思是，你会告诉我你内心最深处的秘密。所以我很想知道你和奥菲莉娅昨晚做了什么。
I believe it. He should have been a little bit-- show me that I'm truly Hamlet's friend. Don't wait till I get to the end of Act V and I'm getting ready to drink a cup of poison and you stop me. You know? Let me know down the line, man, that I'm really your friend, you know?
我相信这一点。他应该稍微——让我感觉到我真的是哈姆雷特的朋友。别等到我到了第五幕末尾，准备喝下一杯毒药时你才阻止我。你知道吗？伙计，在过程中让我知道我真的是你的朋友，你懂吗？
Have you ever heard anybody talk about Shakespeare's characters this way? Hutch was always doing this-- talking tough, but then betraying a real gift for literary criticism. Call it his inner minnow. In fact, he pointed out a weakness in the structure of the story I'd never heard before in all my experience with the play-- that Hamlet's dilemma over killing Claudius isn't really much of a dilemma.
你有没有听过别人这样谈论莎士比亚的角色？哈奇总是这样——说话强硬，但随后流露出真正的文学评论天赋。称之为他内心的小鱼。事实上，他指出了我所有关于这出戏的经验中从未听过的故事结构弱点——哈姆雷特对杀死克劳狄斯的纠结其实并不是什么纠结。
I don't see the conflict. I don't see what Hamlet is dealing with, man, that-- oh, I should kill the king now. I shouldn't kill him now. No, you knew once your father said, revenge, you knew you was going to do this. So what's the hubbub about? Do it.
我不明白冲突在哪里。我不明白哈姆雷特在处理什么，伙计，那——哦，我现在应该杀国王吗？我不应该杀他吗？不，你父亲说复仇的时候你就知道你会这么做。那么为什么要纠结呢？做吧。
I mean, that's the same way I couldn't see somebody raping my daughter or something and just sitting around. No, no, no, no, no. I got to do you, man. And that's just-- you done. That's why I think Hamlet is an old minnow too, man. He-- you know.
我的意思是，就像我无法想象有人强奸了我的女儿，而我只是坐在那里。不，不，不，不，不。我必须干掉你，伙计。就是这样——你完了。这就是为什么我觉得哈姆雷特也是一条老小鱼，伙计。他——你知道。
Are there no reasons to delay taking swift action, even if you're convinced that you've been wronged? I mean, that's why he stages the play within the play, right? To make sure that Claudius is the bad guy.
难道即便你确信自己受到了冤枉，也没有理由推迟迅速采取行动吗？我的意思是，这就是他为什么要安排“戏中戏”的原因，对吧？为了确保克劳狄斯真的是坏人。
See, that's why we've got to go back. Now, if I'm strong enough to believe in ghosts, you know, I'm strong enough to believe what that ghost tells me. (CHUCKLING) If I'm strong enough to believe you're a ghost, then I'm sure you know what happened to you.
看，这就是我们得回溯的地方。现在，如果我足够强大到相信鬼魂，你知道，我当然足够强大到相信那个鬼魂告诉我的事。（笑声）如果我足够强大到相信你是个鬼魂，那我肯定你知道发生在你身上的一切。
Once Hutch got on this riff, he kept going. Denmark's a prison, Hamlet tells Rosencrantz, in Act II. And Hutch says you could do a version of the play that takes this central metaphor literally. All the characters in the play are types he sees in the yard every day. The Claudiuses, who will do anything for the emblems of power-- money, drugs, high-end tennis shoes; Poloniuses, who kiss up to the powerful; Rosencrantz and Guildensterns.
一旦哈奇开始了这个话题，他就停不下来了。“丹麦是一所监狱”，哈姆雷特在第二幕对罗森格兰兹说。哈奇说你可以制作一个从字面上理解这个中心隐喻的版本。剧中所有的角色都是他在院子里每天见到的类型。那些为权力象征——金钱、毒品、高档网球鞋——做任何事的克劳狄斯；那些向权力献媚的波洛尼厄斯；罗森格兰兹和吉尔登斯特恩。
Rosencrantz and Guildenstern. Oh, man. Administration puts some guys out there just to get some info. Yeah, you got your rats.
罗森格兰兹和吉尔登斯特恩。哦，天哪。管理层安插了一些人只是为了获取信息。是的，你懂的，你的告密者。
And in Hutch's version, he solves the play's structural problem, fabricating a true dilemma for Hamlet by giving him good reasons to kill Claudius and not to kill him.
在哈奇的版本中，他解决了这出戏的结构问题，通过给哈姆雷特提供杀死或不杀克劳狄斯的充分理由，制造了一个真正的困境。
This is the way it would happen. Claudius killed this guy here because the guy had the biggest dope business in prison, or something. Gertrude would be some sissy. You find them everywhere in prison. But the guy they kill be Hamlet's brother.
事情会是这样发生的。克劳狄斯杀了这个家伙，因为那家伙在监狱里有最大的毒品生意，或者类似的事情。格特鲁德会是个娘娘腔。你在监狱里到处都能找到这种人。但他们杀死的人是哈姆雷特的兄弟。
So now, being in the prison world, he must defend that honor. But he got a girl talking about, you only got five years. You know, you did two. Do one more, they're gonna parole you. Come on home, because I love you, and I'm duh-duh-duh-duh. He got another brother in business out there that he can get with to help raise his status. So he got-- he got all these things to look forward to on the street.
所以现在，身处监狱世界，他必须捍卫那种荣誉。但他有个女孩一直在说，你只剩五年了。你知道，你已经坐了两年。再坐一年，你就能假释了。回来吧，因为我爱你，还有巴拉巴拉。他外面还有另一个合伙的兄弟，他可以去找他帮忙提升自己的地位。所以他有——他有所有这些在街上期待的东西。
But if he let that killing go, he'll have the roughest three years of his entire life. He'll be the piss-pot of the institution. So I mean, he got this dilemma. Would he be strong enough to survive that and get out there? Hutch wouldn't. I ain't gonna lie. I-- hey.
但如果他放过那场谋杀，他将度过他一生中最艰难的三年。他将成为监狱里的受气包。所以我的意思是，他陷入了这个困境。他足够强大到挺过这一切并走出去吗？哈奇不会。我不会撒谎。我——嘿。
OK. Places, please, for the top of Act I.
好的。各就各位，请准备开始第一幕。
Two months after my visit with Hutch at the first read-through, I was cleared once again into the old classroom. The actors tell me they've been practicing their lines wherever they can, often shouting them from cell to cell. Agnes has also had local professors come in and lecture. She assigns the cast essays to write about their characters. And the Hamlets have been walking the track, memorizing their lines, as has Danny, the Gravedigger. This rehearsal, they're already tinkering with tempo and intonation. That first read-through seems like eons ago.
在我与哈奇进行第一次剧本研读访问后的两个月，我又一次被批准进入那间旧教室。演员们告诉我，他们一直在任何地方练习台词，经常从牢房到牢房大声喊出来。艾格尼丝还请了当地的教授进来讲课。她给演员们布置了关于他们角色的文章。哈姆雷特们一直在轨道上走着，背诵台词，饰演掘墓人的丹尼也是。这次排练，他们已经在调整节奏和语调。那第一次剧本研读似乎已是遥远的往事了。
This same skull, sir, was, sir, Yorick's skull, the king's jester.
这个头骨，先生，确实，先生，是约里克的头骨，那个国王的弄臣。
This?
这个？
Even that.
正是。
Alas, poor Yorick. I knew him, Horatio.
唉，可怜的约里克。我认识他，霍拉旭。
He hath born me on his back 1,000 times.
他曾一千次把我背在背上。
And now, how abhorred in my imagination it is. My gorge rises at it.
现在，我的想象中它是多么令人厌恶。我的胃里一阵翻江倒海。
A lot of what you see looks like any rehearsal. Agnes is taking notes, a couple of guys are reading to themselves, and the occasional line reading devolves into laughter.
你看到的很多东西看起来就像任何排练一样。艾格尼丝在做笔记，几个家伙在自言自语，偶尔的台词诵读演变成笑声。
I will fight with him, (CHUCKLING) upon the-- this thing.
我要和他决斗，（笑声）关于——这件事。
The scene that's really slaying everyone tonight is the first appearance of Osric, the king's toadying courtier.
今晚真正让每个人都笑翻的场景是奥斯里克的首次登场，国王那个谄媚的廷臣。
Sweet lord, if your lordship were at leisure, I should impart a thing to you from his majesty.
亲爱的大人，如果您的贵体有暇，我应该向您转达一件来自陛下的事。
No, just talk to Paul. Just talk to Paul.
不，只对保罗说话。只对保罗说话。
Just talk to Paul?
只对保罗说话？
Yeah. Come on. Let's stay in the scene.
是的。来吧。我们留在场景里。
My name is Timothy Lantz. I'm 38 years old, and I play the role of Osric. Osric is what they call a fop, which a lot of people tend to say, well, he's-- it's a sexual gender thing where he's homosexual or whatever, but he's not. What he is is a king groupie, a wannabe.
我叫蒂莫西·兰茨。今年38岁，我扮演奥斯里克这个角色。奥斯里克是他们所谓的“花花公子”，很多人倾向于说，嗯，他——这是一种性别的怪癖，他是个同性恋什么的，但他不是。他实际上是一个“国王追星族”，一个想出风头的人。
Tim is the one member of the cast with screen time, one second of it. He used to live in California. And in a Frankie Avalon/Annette Funicello revival, he was in the background in one fleeting camera pan, hitting a volleyball. Tim once ran a trucking company, and like most of the cast doesn't want to discuss his crime. But he does want to talk about how he researched his character-- in the TV room.
蒂姆是剧组中唯一有银幕经验的一位，虽然只有一秒钟。他过去住在加利福尼亚。在一部弗兰基·阿瓦隆/安妮特·方尼塞洛的复兴片中，他在背景里闪过的一个镜头中打排球。蒂姆曾经经营一家货运公司，像大多数演员一样，他不想讨论他的罪行。但他确实想谈谈他是如何研究这个角色的——在电视房里。
There are so many fops in television and movies. Nathan Lane was a little bit too much. I think Robin Williams was a little too hyper. The one that really stood out was David Hyde Pierce, his character of Niles Crane. I'd watch Frasier and kind of look at how he did things and his mannerisms, and it worked out pretty good.
电视和电影里有太多的花花公子了。内森·莱恩那个有点太过了。我觉得罗宾·威廉姆斯那个又太亢奋了。真正突出的一个是戴维·海德·皮尔斯，他饰演的奈尔斯·克雷恩。我会看《欢乐一家亲》，观察他是怎么做动作和他的举止的，效果还不错。
I mean, sir, for his weapon. But in the imputation laid on him by them and his mean, he is unfellowed.
我的意思是，先生，为了他的武器。但根据他人的推断，在那种意味上，他是独一无二的。
What's his weapon?
他的武器是什么？
Rapier and dagger.
刺剑和匕首。
What you say?
你说什么？
Do you think your audience is going to be able to draw the very, sort of, fine distinction you're making between a fop and a gay person?
你认为你的观众能够区分你所做的那种，非常微妙的，花花公子和同性恋者之间的区别吗？
Not really.
说实话，不太行。
To me, this seemed like an especially risky interpretation of the part. But Tim explains that folks on the outside have a TV movie understanding of prison sexuality. There is a small group of gay prisoners in the closet, another smaller group that is actually out, and then there's the vast majority of prisoners-- straight men, not having any sex at all. Just like outside, Tim says.
对我来说，这似乎是一个特别有风险的表演解读。但蒂姆解释说，外面的大众对监狱里的性倾向有一种电视电影式的理解。监狱里有一小群深柜的同性恋囚犯，另一小群实际上是出柜的，然后是绝大多数的囚犯——直男，根本没有任何性行为。就像在外面一样，蒂姆说。
OK, gentle folk, let's refocus. We're going to start where Laertes leaps into the grave.
好的，各位，重新聚焦。我们从雷欧提斯跳进坟墓的地方开始。
Putting on a play in prison is different. First, Agnes always has to deal with some last minute crisis. Tonight, one of the Hamlets can't come. He was assaulted and was placed in solitary for protection. Plus, everyone must be strip-searched in the side room before and after every meeting with Agnes or with me. Worse, it's incredibly hot. The room is stifling. The only relief is an ancient stand-up fan in the corner. And a lot of the time, the actors are just trying to figure out what their lines mean. Here's Chris, one of the Hamlets.
在监狱里演戏是不一样的。首先，艾格尼丝总是得处理一些最后一刻的危机。今晚，其中一个哈姆雷特没能来。他被袭击了，为了安全被关进了禁闭室。另外，每次和艾格尼丝或我见面之前和之后，每个人都必须在侧室接受搜身。更糟糕的是，天气热得不可思议。房间里闷热难耐。唯一的缓解是角落里那台老旧的立式风扇。而且很多时候，演员们只是在试图弄明白他们的台词是什么意思。这是克里斯，哈姆雷特之一。
There is a piece of dialogue I give in V.ii in which I'm talking to Horatio about how I got Rosencrantz and Guildenstern. And it starts like, "Up from my cabin, sea-gown scarf'd about me."
我在第五幕第二场有一段台词，我正在和霍拉旭谈论我如何对付罗森格兰兹和吉尔登斯特恩。它是这样开头的，“从船舱出来，海服围着我。”
Up from my cabin, my sea-gown scarfed about me.
从船舱出来，我的海服围着我。
I didn't know what that meant. And one thing Agnes will do, she'll stop us in mid-line. And she says, what does that mean?
我不知道那是什么意思。艾格尼丝会做的一件事是，她会在台词中间打断我们。她说，那是什么意思？
Let's go back. Remember that what you're wrapped in is not a cloak. It's fog. How do you describe it?
我们回去吧。记住，你裹着的不是一件斗篷。是雾。你如何描述它？
Sea-gown.
海服。
Your sea-gown.
你的海服。
Scarfed about me.
围着我。
Yeah. Your sea-gown scarfed about you is the fog.
是的。你的海服围着你就是那层雾。
I knew that.
我知道那个。
Yeah. But now you've got to act it.
是的。但现在你必须表演出来。
The sea-gown scarfed about me is the fog. I'm out at night. And it's the flow of the words. Up from my cabin, sea-gown scarfed about me, groped I in the dark to find out them. Shakespeare really put some work in this-- and this is the only play I've really studied from him. But he really is good.
围着我的海服就是雾。我在深夜。这是词语的流动。从船舱出来，海服围着我，我在黑暗中摸索着找到他们。莎士比亚确实在这上面下了一番功夫——这是我真正研究过的他唯一的剧作。但他确实很棒。
OK. Pick up the pace, y'all.
好的。加快节奏，各位。
Zip.
Zip. (嗖)
Zap.
Zap. (咂)
Zop.
Zop. (奏)
Zip.
Zap.
Zop.
After a few months, the rehearsals begin to resemble a routine. They always start with some silly voice relaxation exercises.
几个月后，排练开始变得像例行公事。他们总是以一些傻傻的发声放松练习开始。
Zip.
Zap.
Zop.
Zip.
Zap.
Zop.
Zip.
(DELAYED) Zap.
(延迟) Zap.
[ALL CHUCKLING]
[众人笑声]
No, that's not him.
不，那不是他。
The cast is such a mix. There's Chris, who's a member of Toastmasters International, and when not rehearsing likes to listen to Journey on his Walkman, while his good pal Brat, a former gang-banger, has a subscription to a lapidary magazine. Then there's Edgar, a former Post Office employee, and Mike, a fight coordinator and a devout Wiccan. And then Stan, who's obviously a college educated businessman, now trying his hand at writing Zane Grey Westerns. And of course, there's Hutch, the killer whale.
剧组里的人混杂得很有趣。有克里斯，他是国际演讲会的成员，不排练时喜欢在随身听里听Journey乐队的歌；他的好朋友布拉特，一个前黑帮成员，订阅了一本宝石加工杂志。还有埃德加，一个前邮局员工；迈克，一名格斗协调员，也是虔诚的威卡教徒。还有斯坦，显然是一个受过高等教育的商人，现在试着写赞恩·格雷式的西部小说。当然，还有大哈奇，那条虎鲸。
What keeps them coming back to D-168, where Agnes, this tiny, tough lady, bosses them around? Here's Edgar.
是什么让他们回到D-168室，在那里接受艾格尼丝这位矮小、强硬的女士指挥？这是埃德加。
She makes us feel human, man. She really does. When I go in there, I have to take my clothes off and get butt naked and bend over and spread my cheeks so some man can look up my butt, you know, all the dehuman-- the humiliating things that they do to us here. And when she comes in and does what she does, for that minute, them two and a half hours, all these guys with PhDs and can be doing other things, they come in, I at least can feel human in here.
她让我们感觉自己是个人，伙计。她确实做到了。当我进去时，我得脱光衣服，弯下腰，分开屁股，好让男人检查我的臀部，你知道，所有那些他们在这里对我们做的非人——屈辱的事情。而当她进来做她所做的时，在那一分钟，那两个半小时里，那些有博士学位可以做其他事情的家伙们进来，我至少在这里能感觉自己是个人。
I think this is taking me to being sane. For just one day, just one day I'm sane enough, you know?
我觉得这让我保持清醒。就为了这一天，就为了这一天，我足够清醒，你知道吗？
This is Brat Jones, another one of the Hamlets.
这是布拉特·琼斯，另一位哈姆雷特。
If you don't keep exercising your mind, then you start to lose it, right? You know, that's possible, right? This gives me an opportunity to see a society beyond what I'm used to. I'm familiar with rap music and videos and big butts on the TV and all that. But let me come back to something that I'm not familiar with. You know, let me get into something else. You know, that did open my eyes into getting into reading Sylvia Plath and Frost and Wadsworth and different other people.
如果你不继续锻炼你的大脑，那你就会开始失去它，对吧？你知道，这很有可能，对吧？这给了我一个机会去看看我习惯之外的社会。我熟悉说唱音乐和录像带，电视里的大屁股等等。但让我回到我不熟悉的东西上来。你知道，让我投入到别的东西里去。你知道，这确实打开了我的眼界，让我开始阅读西尔维娅·普拉斯、弗罗斯特、华兹华斯和其他人的作品。
Everybody had powerful answers for why they were in the play. One guy with a third grade education level said that he was surprised to find out that he wasn't stupid, just uneducated. And for almost all of them, acting was beside the point. But one inmate got bit by the drama bug, and bit hard. His first step onto the boards was a revelation.
每个人都有关于为什么参与这部戏的有力回答。一个只有三年级文化水平的家伙说，他惊讶地发现自己并不笨，只是没受过教育。对他们大多数人来说，表演本身是次要的。但有一个囚犯被戏剧虫咬了一口，而且咬得很深。他踏上舞台的第一步就是一场启示。
I'm James Word. I'm 32 years old. And I play the role of Laertes. My wife told me that I should be an actor. And she's like, you can act. You should be an actor. She's had the opportunity to see me deal with certain people on certain levels, and she's seen me change my--
我叫詹姆斯·沃德。今年32岁。我扮演雷欧提斯这个角色。我妻子告诉我，我应该当个演员。她说，你能演戏。你应该当个演员。她有机会看到我在某些层面上应对某些人，她看到了我的改变——
Wait. Certain people on certain levels. OK, come on. Let's-- as we say in the editorial business, let's air that out a little bit.
等等。某些层面上应对某些人。好的，来吧。正如我们在编辑行业所说，让我们把话说明白一点。
Well, I've always wanted to be a con. And I've always wanted people to like me. I wanted to be liked. And the environment that I was in, people liked the bad guy. You know, those were the heroes in our neighborhoods, the bad guy.
嗯，我一直想当个罪犯。而且我一直想让别人喜欢我。我想被人喜欢。而在我所处的环境中，人们喜欢坏蛋。你知道，那些是我们街区里的英雄，坏蛋。
And so I went from this real quiet church guy to this real bad guy. You know, and I'd get around them, and I'd be like, yeah, I'm this and that, and would act it-- you know what I'm saying? Act big, bad, tough, and I don't care, when that really wasn't me.
所以我从一个真正安静的去教堂的家伙变成了一个真正的坏蛋。你知道，我会围绕在他们身边，我会表现得——你知道我在说什么吗？装得很强硬、很坏，我不在乎，而那根本不是我。
Because when I went home at night, I felt bad about what I did, and most of the time was scared to death doing what I was doing. And my wife saw that. And I think that's one of the reasons why she's like, you can be an actor.
因为当我晚上回家时，我对我的所作所为感到难过，而且大多数时候在做那些事的时候，我害怕得要死。我妻子看到了这一点。我想这就是她觉得“你可以当个演员”的原因之一。
James Word looks like an actor. He's young and handsome with a smile that can carry him through just about any situation. He plays Laertes, the brother of Ophelia. For the first few acts, Laertes was played by an Amish pedophile. That's another story.
詹姆斯·沃德看起来就像个演员。他年轻帅气，笑容可以让他应对任何情况。他扮演奥菲莉娅的哥哥雷欧提斯。前几幕中，雷欧提斯是由一个阿米什恋童癖扮演的。那是另一个故事。
But the Amish pedophile got transferred, and so it's almost legend in the prison now, like something out of 42nd Street. James Word stepped into the role. He created a sensation among the cast when they realized what a really forceful performance could do for a character. Word made a lasting impression, even on the killer whale.
但那个阿米什恋童癖被转狱了，所以现在在监狱里这几乎成了传说，就像《第42街》里的情节一样。詹姆斯·沃德接替了这个角色。当剧组意识到一场真正强有力的表演能为一个角色带来什么时，他引起了轰动。沃德留下了深刻的印象，甚至连那条虎鲸都被打动了。
You come along and in Act IV, and you get this guy, James Word. And Word's playing Laertes. And he was hittin' it, especially when he was mourning the death of Ophelia. Is it Scene 4 or something?
你出现了，在第四幕，你得到了这个家伙，詹姆斯·沃德。沃德扮演雷欧提斯。他演得很棒，特别是在他哀悼奥菲莉娅之死的时候。是第四场还是什么？
He makes his entrance. And he's going to be after the king and the queen. Stop them. Hold up. And man, you should have seen this guy Word man. He come in there like-- dropped to his knees. And he did, why! Why! I said, man, that should have been my part there.
他登场了。他要去找国王和王后。阻止他们。停下。伙计，你应该看看这个叫沃德的家伙。他走进来，就像——跪在地上。他说，为什么！为什么！我说，伙计，那部分本该是我的角色。
I knew I had done a good job. You know, I knew I had done a good job. But when it was over, you know, and everybody was leaving and shaking hands and interacting with each other, the comments that was coming afterwards-- you know, we had our questions and answers. So many people was just-- man, you were so good. Have you done this before? You should do this more. You should continue this.
我知道我做得很好。你知道，我知道我做得很好。但当演出结束，每个人都离开，握手，相互交流时，随之而来的评价——你知道，我们有问答环节。很多人只是说——伙计，你太棒了。你以前做过这个吗？你应该多做这个。你应该继续下去。
And that feeling for me was just-- it was one of the best feelings I've ever felt. It was like the day my daughter was born. And it made me want to be better. Not just in acting. I mean, it just opened up a whole world for me, you know? Like, man, if I apply myself, I can pretty much do whatever I want.
那种感觉对我来说只是——那是我感受过的最好的感觉之一。就像我女儿出生的那天一样。这让我想变得更好。不仅是在表演上。我的意思是，它为我打开了一个全新的世界，你知道吗？就像，伙计，如果我付出努力，我几乎可以做任何我想做的事。
O treble woe, fall 10 times treble, on that cursed head, whose wicked deed that most ingenious sense deprived thee of. Now, pile your dust upon the quick and dead, till of this flat a mountain you have made to overtop old Pelion, or the skyish head of blue Olympus.
哦，三重痛苦，降临十倍于我，在那个被诅咒的人头上，他的邪恶行为剥夺了你那聪慧的感觉。现在，把尘土堆在生者和死者身上，直到你把这一平地堆成一座山，高过古老的皮立翁山，或者高耸入云的奥林匹斯山。
The first chance I get to see Word in action is at tonight's rehearsal, where Laertes goes to the grave of his sister Ophelia. Word was a natural, and talked about acting that way too. Laertes' emotions in the final act roller-coaster from grief to fury to shameful regret. To pull it off, Word channels Laertes' character in a way that should make any method actor cringe with jealousy.
我见到沃德表演的第一次机会是今晚的排练，雷欧提斯前往他妹妹奥菲莉娅的坟墓。沃德是天生的演员，谈论表演的方式也一样。雷欧提斯在最后一幕的情绪在悲伤、愤怒和羞耻的悔恨中过山车般起伏。为了完美呈现，沃德以一种会让任何方法派演员因嫉妒而畏缩的方式引导着雷欧提斯这个角色。
Coming into Act IV, he was very angry, violently angry. And I can identify with that, and I can play that role very well, because I've been playing that role all my life.
进入第四幕时，他非常愤怒，暴怒。我可以体会那种情绪，我可以演好那个角色，因为我一生都在演那个角色。
Must there no more be done?
难道没有更多的事要做了吗？
No more be done.
没有更多的事要做了。
Lay her in the earth, and from her fair and unpolluted flesh may violets spring. I tell thee, old churlish priest, a ministering angel shall my sister be when thou liest howling.
把她放进土里，从她那纯洁无瑕的肉体里可能会长出紫罗兰。我告诉你，这个粗鲁的老牧师，当你在下面哀嚎的时候，我妹妹将成为一个侍奉的天使。
You know what I'm saying? And Laertes, he falls into the manipulation. And he becomes a bad guy for a little while because he's being deceitful now. You know, I never really looked at it, and it's somewhat cowardly. And I can relate that to my past life as a criminal.
你知道我在说什么吗？雷欧提斯，他陷入了操纵之中。他变成了一个坏蛋，有一会儿，因为他现在变得虚伪了。你知道，我以前从来没这样看过，而且这有点懦弱。我可以把它和我的犯罪过去联系起来。
To put a gun in somebody's face, that's an unfair advantage. You know, and that's a cowardly act. That's what criminals are. We're cowards. You know, when we're criminals, we are cowards.
把枪顶在别人的脸上，那是不公平的优势。你知道，那是一种懦弱的行为。这就是罪犯的本质。我们是懦夫。你知道，当我们成为罪犯时，我们就是懦夫。
Do you feel like you can be Laertes because so much of Laertes is inside James Word?
你觉得你能演好雷欧提斯，是因为雷欧提斯有很大一部分就在詹姆斯·沃德体内吗？
I am Laertes. I am. I am.
我就是雷欧提斯。我是。我就是。
Coming up, what the ghost of Hamlet's father can teach you about murder. In a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，哈姆雷特的父亲的鬼魂能教你关于谋杀的什么道理。稍后回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. If you're just tuning in, what we're doing today is that we're devoting our whole show to Jack Hitt's story, from the Missouri Eastern Correctional Center, where over the course of six months Jack watched prisoners rehearse and stage Act V of Hamlet. Again, here's Jack.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。如果你刚调过来，我们今天做的就是把整期节目贡献给杰克·希特关于密苏里州东部惩教中心的故事，在那里，杰克在六个月的时间里观察囚犯们排练并上演了《哈姆雷特》第五幕。再次欢迎杰克。
As the performance day grew closer and I spoke to more and more of the actors, it became clear that each actor used his past, in dense psychological ways, to understand his part. All the Hamlets saw themselves in their version of the Dane, and Edgar would stop me in the hall to tell me that he thought evil King Claudius had some redeeming qualities. But for one actor, the relationship was even more complicated. He used his part to help understand his past.
随着演出日的临近，我与越来越多的演员交谈，很明显，每个演员都在以深刻的心理方式利用自己的过去来理解他们的角色。所有的哈姆雷特都在这个丹麦王子身上看到了自己，埃德加会在走廊拦住我，告诉我他认为邪恶的克劳狄斯国王有一些可取之处。但对于一名演员来说，这种关系甚至更加复杂。他利用自己的角色来帮助理解他的过去。
My name is Danny Waller. I'm 44 years old. The character that I've played was the ghost of Hamlet's father. The reason I chose that, when I first read the script, the words jumped out at me. And they made me feel things that I haven't felt before.
我叫丹尼·沃勒。今年44岁。我扮演的角色是哈姆雷特的父亲的鬼魂。我选择这个的原因是，当我第一次读剧本时，这些台词触动了我。它们让我感受到了以前从未有过的感觉。
What in your-- what in your experience drew you to those particular words?
你自己的——你的经历中是什么吸引你选择了那些特定的台词？
I took a man's life. And, uh, I felt he was talking to me through that-- that he wanted me to know what I put him through.
我夺走了一个人的生命。而且，呃，我觉得他正在通过那个——那个在和我说话，他想让我知道我让他经历了什么。
"I am thy father's spirit, doomed for a certain term to walk the night, and for the day confined to fast in fires, 'til the foul crimes done in my days of nature are burnt and purged away. But that I am forbid to tell the secrets of my prison-house, I could a tale unfold, whose lightest words would harrow up thy soul, freeze thy young blood, and make thy two eyes, like stars, start from their spheres."
“我是你父亲的灵魂，注定在夜晚徘徊，白天则被禁锢在火焰中忍受饥渴，直到我在世间所犯下的卑劣罪行被烧灼、净化。如果不是被禁止说出我那监狱里的秘密，我能讲述一个故事，它最轻微的只言片语也会让你灵魂战栗，冻结你年轻的血液，让你那两只眼睛像星星一样脱离眼眶。”
There's one other spot that goes like this. "Thus was I, sleeping, by a brother's hand of life, of crown, of queen, at once dispatched, cut off even in the blossoms of my sin, no reckoning made, but sent to my account with all my imperfections on my head." And it was pretty much the same way with him. He was taken before his time.
还有一个地方是这样的。“就这样，我在睡眠中被兄弟之手夺走了生命、王冠、王后，一次性被消灭，死在了罪孽的花苞中，没有经过审判，带着我头顶上所有的不完美被送去了结算。”他也是这样。他在他本该离世的时间之前被带走了。
So when you read the character, do you feel like-- who is talking when you say those lines?
所以当你读这个角色时，你是否觉得——当你念这些台词时，是谁在说话？
I'm the body up there. But the words are coming from mostly, uh-- William Pride, the man that I killed. He's mostly the one talking.
我在台上作为躯体。但这些话主要来自——威廉·普莱德，那个被我杀掉的人。主要是他在说话。
There's not much defense between the actor and the word as you get with an actor who puts his or her training between the two. These guys call it like they see it. And it's true. It's just dead true.
这些家伙不像那些在演员和剧本之间放置了表演训练的演员，他们和台词之间没什么隔阂。他们有话直说。而且这是事实，是极其残酷的真相。
That's Agnes, the director. Besides putting on plays in the Missouri Eastern Correctional Center visiting room, she has mounted shows on more familiar stages-- the acclaimed Actor's Studio in New York, the Berkshire Festival in Stockbridge, and the Eugene O'Neill Theater Center in Connecticut. After becoming the artistic director of the New Theater in St. Louis, she started an outreach program to take professional actors doing dramatic works by writers like Don DeLillo and perform them before prison audiences. In time, the prisoners became the actors. And in more time, this side project took over her entire theater company. Now this is what she does-- directing prisoners, who may not have the chops of professional actors but have an intimacy with the material that doesn't exist anywhere else.
那是艾格尼丝，导演。除了在密苏里州东部惩教中心的探视室排演戏剧外，她还在更熟悉的舞台上执导过——纽约著名的演员工作室、斯托克布里奇的伯克希尔艺术节和康涅狄格州的尤金·奥尼尔戏剧中心。在成为圣路易斯新剧团的艺术总监后，她发起了一个外展项目，让专业演员表演像唐·德里罗这样作家的戏剧作品给囚犯观众看。随着时间的推移，囚犯们成了演员。又过了些时间，这个副业接管了她整个剧团。现在，这就是她的工作——指导囚犯，他们可能没有专业演员的底子，但对剧本有着世界上任何其他地方都不存在的亲密感。
When Claudius is in the chapel and speaks about his sin and his regret and his ability to undo it, it broke my heart. Because the man playing it felt all of those things fully. And you know, I know these guys have deep regrets. But it was palpable. The audience was stunned. You could hear a pin drop. And that was especially true with the inmate audience. He says, oh, my offense is rank. It smells to heaven. It hath the primal, eldest, curse upon it. A brother's murder.
当克劳狄斯在礼拜堂谈论他的罪恶、遗憾以及他无力扭转这一切时，我的心碎了。因为饰演他的那个人充分感受到了所有这些。你知道，我知道这些家伙有深重的悔恨。但这非常触动人心。观众惊呆了。你可以听到针掉在地上的声音。对于囚犯观众来说尤其如此。他说，哦，我的罪行是如此严重。它发出恶臭直到天堂。它有着最原始、最古老的诅咒。兄弟谋杀。
A brother's murder. Pray can I not, though inclination be sharp as will. My stronger guilt defeats my strong intent. What if this cursed hand were thicker than itself with brother's blood? Is there not rain enough in the sweet heavens to wash it white as snow?
兄弟谋杀。祈祷我做不到，尽管意图像意志一样尖锐。我更强烈的负罪感挫败了我强烈的意图。如果这只被诅咒的手沾满了兄弟的鲜血，厚得不能再厚了，怎么办？难道甜美的天堂里没有足够的雨水把它洗得像雪一样白吗？
My name is Edgar Evans. And I'm 39 years old. And I play the king, King Claudius, in Hamlet.
我叫埃德加·埃文斯。今年39岁。我在《哈姆雷特》中扮演国王，克劳狄斯国王。
And like a man to double business bound, I stand in pause where I shall first begin and both neglect.
就像一个被双重责任束缚的人，我停在原处，不知道从哪里开始，两边都忽略了。
I don't consider myself no great actor or nothing, but I try to do the best I can. And when I did the speech, I was looking upward. The chapel was at an incline there. And I was just looking up toward the top, and it was like no one was there but me.
我不认为自己是什么伟大的演员，但我尽我所能。当我演这段演讲时，我望着上面。礼拜堂在那里有一个倾斜的角度。我只是向上望着顶端，感觉那里除了我之外空无一人。
I literally-- I honestly didn't see a soul in the chapel when I was saying this. Maybe even-- and I'm just-- I'm not saying this. It seemed almost like I was praying this actual speech to God.
我真的——我诚实地说，当我说这段话时，礼拜堂里我一个人也没看到。甚至可能——我不是在说大话。这看起来几乎就像我在向神祈祷这段演讲。
But O, what form of prayer can serve my turn. Forgive me my foul murder? That cannot be, since I am still possessed of those effects for which I did the murder-- my crown, my own ambition, and my queen.
但哦，什么形式的祈祷能拯救我呢？原谅我那卑劣的谋杀？那不可能，因为我仍然占有着我因谋杀而得到的那些果实——我的王冠、我自己的野心，还有我的王后。
I have a wife and four kids. And by being incarcerated, I feel that I've really let them down. When I said that speech and my wife was here in the visiting room, I don't know if it had an impact on her. I don't even know if she truly understood all of the content. But I wanted her to hear that speech more than anybody.
我有妻子和四个孩子。因为被监禁，我觉得我真的辜负了他们。当我说那段话时，我妻子就在探视室里，我不知道这对她是否有影响。我甚至不知道她是否真正理解所有的内容。但我比任何人都想让她听到那段演讲。
O, wretched state, O, bosom black as death, O, limed soul, struggling to be free art more engaged. Help, angels. Make assay. Bow, stubborn knee, and hearts with strings of steel, be soft as sinews of the newborn babe. All may be well.
哦，悲惨的状态，哦，像死一样黑的心，哦，粘了胶的灵魂，挣扎着想自由却反而深陷其中。帮助我，天使们。尝试一下。弯下你倔强的膝盖，那颗用钢弦做成的心，要变得像新生儿的筋骨一样柔软。一切都会好起来的。
Edgar wouldn't tell me his crime. Although I found myself playing a constant guessing game with all of them about this, they wouldn't discuss the past. That was then, they said. This is now. But I had to know. So one morning, instead of visiting, I went to downtown St. Louis, not far from the Arch, and sat in a records depository reading old case files.
埃德加没有告诉我他的罪行。虽然我发现自己一直在和他们所有人玩猜谜游戏，但他们不愿讨论过去。那是过去，他们说。这是现在。但我必须知道。所以一天早上，我不去探访，而是去了市中心，在法院附近，坐在记录保存处读旧的案件档案。
It was more horrible than I thought. One guy I particularly liked shot a man in the head twice at point-blank range. Another of my new friends raped his pubescent daughter, impregnating her. Later, there was an abortion. Another friend grabbed a man getting out of a car, put a gun to his chest during a robbery, and pulled the trigger. Others had sodomized children-- younger children, the age of my own children.
那比我预想的更可怕。我特别喜欢的一个家伙近距离朝一个男人的头上开了两枪。我另一个新朋友强奸了他未成年的女儿，让她怀了孕。后来，做了流产。另一个朋友在抢劫时抓住一个下车的男人，把枪顶在他的胸口，扣动了扳机。其他人则鸡奸了儿童——比我自己的孩子还要小的孩子。
I didn't fall asleep for a long time in my frigid Ramada Inn room. At 3:00 in the morning, I had one of those cinematic nightmares. I dreamed that a very good friend of mine, an editor at a magazine, had me over to dinner. She got angry with someone else there, pulled out a gun, and plugged him twice, right in the face. Then she asked me not to talk about it with anybody.
我在冰冷的华美达酒店房间里很长一段时间无法入睡。凌晨三点，我做了一个类似电影场景的噩梦。我梦见我的一个好朋友，一家杂志的编辑，邀请我共进晚餐。她对那里的另一个人发火，掏出一把枪，朝着他的脸开了两枪。然后她要求我不要跟任何人谈论这件事。
I panicked. And the next thing I knew, I was sitting up in my hotel bed, panting like a sprinter. It didn't take Freud to figure out what it meant. Someone I knew and liked was a murderer. I wanted to talk to the cast about this, but I was anxious. I know this sounds crazy, but I was afraid it might hurt their feelings. I felt like they had betrayed me. But strangely, I felt that I had betrayed them too. There was only one day left to talk, just before the final performance. So before curtain, I asked Brat to sit down with me. I could barely spit out my question.
我惊慌失措。下一刻，我发现自己正坐在酒店的床上，像短跑运动员一样气喘吁吁。不用弗洛伊德也能看出这意味着什么。我认识且喜欢的一个人是个杀人犯。我想和剧组谈谈这个，但我很焦虑。我知道这听起来很疯狂，但我担心这可能会伤害他们的感情。我觉得他们背叛了我。但奇怪的是，我觉得我也背叛了他们。只剩下一天时间谈话，就在最后一次演出前。所以，在开场前，我请布拉特坐下来。我几乎吐不出问题来。
You know, we came in here three months ago, or five months ago, and met you all for the first time as actors. And so yesterday, we decided to go down to City Hall and read everybody's record. And so we read everybody's record. And I have to say, since we met-- you know, since I met you as an actor first and now I know what you did, it's very hard for me to wrap my mind around this other guy that's on paper. And so I want to know how you do it. How do you square the Brat Jones of-- what was it, 13 years ago-- yeah, yeah-- with the one that I see on the stage tonight.
你知道，我们三个月前，或者五个月前来到这里，第一次以演员的身份见到你们所有人。昨天，我们决定去市政厅读每个人的记录。所以我们读了所有人的记录。我不得不说，自从我们见面——你知道，自从我先是以演员身份认识你，而现在我知道了你做了什么，要让我的大脑接受纸上的那个“那个人”真的非常困难。所以我想要知道你是怎么做到的。你是如何把13年前的那个布拉特·琼斯——是的，是的——和你今晚在舞台上表现的那个你调和在一起的。
It's taken a lot of practice. I'm trying to discover who I am now. It's not been easy. I was off into the drugs and all those things when I got locked up for that case. And I slowly had to come out of those things. Because I always knew in the back of my mind that I had already went to the lowest point in life. So now it was time to see what I could do as far as going to the highest point in life.
这需要很多练习。我正在努力发掘现在的我是谁。这并不容易。当我因那个案子被关起来时，我沉迷于毒品和所有那些事情。我慢慢地不得不摆脱那些东西。因为我内心深处一直都知道，我已经跌落到了人生的最低点。所以现在是时候看看我在追求人生最高点方面能做些什么了。
It was a hard question for any of them to answer. They all said the same thing. But I'm this guy now, I'm not that guy. Are we forever the prisoner of our actions? It's a good question. It was Hamlet's question, and it's the unresolvable conflict in our penal system.
对于他们中的任何一个来说，这都是个难以回答的问题。他们都说了同样的话。但我现在是这个人，我不是那个人。我们永远是我们行为的囚徒吗？这是一个好问题。这是哈姆雷特的问题，也是我们刑罚制度中无法解决的冲突。
Why do we put people in jail? To rehabilitate them and restore them to our company, or to punish them, regardless of how much they might change? One can't hold both these ideas in one's mind simultaneously. That's why our prison debates on TV and in Congress are so vehement and incoherent. The two sides cannot be squared by mere politics. They can't even be squared by the people at the center of the debate. Here's Danny.
我们为什么要让人坐牢？是为了让他们改过自新并让他们回归社会，还是为了惩罚他们，无论他们发生了多大的变化？一个人不可能同时持有这两种观点。这就是为什么我们在电视和国会上关于监狱的辩论如此激烈且语无伦次的原因。两方不能通过单纯的政治来调和。它们甚至不能被处于辩论中心的人调和。这是丹尼。
When I first got this sentence, I said, yeah, I'll go ahead and just die in here because I don't deserve to be out there the way I am. You know, that was 13, 14 years ago. But a person changes. I'm no longer the criminal I used to be. I know that I will not do any other crimes out there. But I took a man's life. Do I deserve to be out there? I cannot say.
当我第一次拿到这个判决时，我说，好吧，我就在里面死掉吧，因为我不配在外面像我这样。你知道，那是13、14年前的事了。但人是会变的。我不再是过去那个罪犯了。我知道我在外面不会再犯任何罪。但我夺走了一个人的生命。我配在外面吗？我无法说。
Hamlet, thou art slain. No medicine in the world can do thee good. In thee is not a half an hour's life. No medicine in the world, blah blah blah. I can't get it. I forgot. Line.
哈姆雷特，你被杀了。世界上没有任何药能救你。你活不到半小时了。世界上没有任何药，吧啦吧啦吧啦。我不记得了。台词。
The treacherous instrument is in thy hand.
那把致命的凶器就在你手里。
It's opening night, dress rehearsal. Word has flubbed his line again. Things aren't going well. The only time the authorities would allow a dress rehearsal is in the hour before actual curtain. This is the first time the cast has seen the acting stage, the first time in costume, the first time they have real props, skulls and shovels.
是首演之夜，彩排。沃德又忘词了。事情进行得不顺利。当局允许彩排的唯一时间是在正式开演前的一小时。这是剧组第一次见到真正的舞台，第一次穿上戏服，第一次拥有真正的道具，头骨和铲子。
The shovel is a story in itself, given every prison fear of shovels. You can use them to dig tunnels, remember. The authorities insisted on using only a flimsy cardboard replica. Everyone is tense, even Agnes.
铲子本身就是一个故事，考虑到监狱里对铲子的恐惧。记住，你可以用它们挖隧道。当局坚持只使用薄薄的纸板模型。每个人都很紧张，甚至艾格尼丝也是。
Guys, let's double the pace so we can get through this, get it all out. The sight is dismal.
伙计们，我们把节奏加快一倍，这样我们就能熬过去，把这一切都释放出来。这景象真凄凉。
The sight is dismal.
这景象真凄凉。
And our affairs--
而我们的事务——
We are in the prison chapel where their first performance will be held before an audience of inmates. Six months after my first visit, it is, at last, showtime.
我们就在监狱的礼拜堂里，他们的第一次演出将在囚犯观众面前举行。在我第一次访问六个月后，终于，表演时间到了。
Alan, how are you doing today?
艾伦，你今天怎么样？
Armed guards let the audience in the door, one by one. Agnes calls her actors together in a corner and gives them the final pep talk.
武装警卫一个接一个地让观众进门。艾格尼丝把她的演员们召集在一个角落，给他们最后的鼓励。
Paul, Edgar, could I have you? OK. Things to think about. Make sure to stand still on yours and other people's punchlines. If something falls apart, pick it up, go somewhere with it. Make up words. I don't think anybody here has memorized it, so we're safe.
保罗，埃德加，能过来一下吗？好的。需要考虑的事情。确保在你的和别人的笑话梗上站定。如果事情乱套了，捡起来，带着它继续。自己编词。我想这里没人完全背下来，所以我们很安全。
And mostly, this afternoon people were working so hard I don't think you had much fun. Hard work's behind us. This is the night to just have a blast.
最重要的是，今天下午大家工作得太辛苦了，我觉得你们没怎么享受。辛苦工作已经过去了。今晚是尽情玩乐的时刻。
Say "One for the team."
说“为团队贡献一次”。
One for the team.
为团队贡献一次。
Ready, set-- hoo-ha!
预备，开始——呼哈！
Once the play starts, Danny and Stan deliver their lines OK, but all that antique Elizabethan wordplay isn't connecting with the audience. But then midway through the scene, the crowd starts to really respond to the emotion in Ophelia's funeral march. Laertes is the last mourner, humming at the side of the grave, tossing rose petals on her corpse. Right away, the action picks up. The Hamlets appear, taunting Laertes about the sincerity of his grief. They quarrel and exchange insults. A duel is proposed, which culminates in the last sword fight scene.
一旦表演开始，丹尼和斯坦的台词说得还可以，但所有那些古老的伊丽莎白时代的双关语并没有与观众建立联系。但随后场景中途，人群开始真正地对奥菲莉娅葬礼行进中的情绪做出反应。雷欧提斯是最后的送葬者，在坟墓边哼着曲子，把玫瑰花瓣撒在她的尸体上。行动立刻加快了。哈姆雷特们出现了，嘲弄雷欧提斯哀悼的诚意。他们争吵并互相谩骂。一场决斗被提出来，演变成最后一场剑斗场景。
[DRUM ROLL]
[鼓声]
Come, begin!
来，开始吧！
Most directors block the scene as a professional fencing match. Agnes has it looking like a knife fight in an alley. The audience totally gets it. Word holds his arms slightly out from his sides, his hand gripping his sword like he would a shiv. He and one of the Hamlets are circling each other, like thugs. Word jerks his shoulders forward-- a pure back alley feint, a fake movement to intimidate his opponent, something all of them have probably seen right in the yard.
大多数导演把这个场景编排成专业的击剑比赛。艾格尼丝让它看起来像巷子里的械斗。观众完全看懂了。沃德的双臂稍微向两侧伸开，手紧紧握着剑，就像他握着一把自制刀一样。他和其中一个哈姆雷特像暴徒一样互相盘旋。沃德猛地向前耸动肩膀——一个纯粹的小巷假动作，为了威慑对手而做的虚晃，这是他们每个人可能都在院子里见过的东西。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
Then the room goes quiet, as the actors starts slicing one another, leading to Laertes' death scene.
然后房间安静了下来，演员们开始互相割伤，引向雷欧提斯的死亡场景。
Hamlet, thou art slain. No medicine in the world can do thee good. In thee, there's not half an hour's life. The treacherous instrument is in your hand, unbated and envenomed. The foul practice has turned itself on me. Lo, here I lie, never to rise again. Exchange forgiveness with me, noble Hamlet. Let mine and my father's death be not upon thee.
哈姆雷特，你被杀了。世界上没有任何药能救你。你活不到半小时了。致命的器械在你手里，既没封头又浸了毒。卑劣的诡计已经报应到了我身上。看，我躺在这里，再也站不起来了。和我交换宽恕吧，高贵的哈姆雷特。不要让我和我父亲的死算在你的头上。
The audience, like a living thing, leans forward in unison to watch Word slide down the chapel wall and die. There are no cackles of discomfort, no shouts from the gallery. Just breathless silence, the silence of recognition.
观众们像一个活生生的东西，齐刷刷地前倾，看着沃德顺着礼拜堂的墙壁滑下并死去。没有不舒服的咯咯笑声，没有来自看台的叫喊。只有屏住呼吸的沉默，认同的沉默。
In all, there were three performances. And on the final night, before family and dignitaries, the entire cast found the magic that Paul said would happen during that first read-through. The actors knew that this would be the last time they get to perform as a group. So when Danny and Stan came out for their final gravedigger appearance, somehow those Elizabethan jokes worked.
总共进行了三场演出。在最后一场之夜，在家人和政要面前，全体演员找到了保罗在第一次剧本研读时说的那种魔力。演员们知道这将是他们作为团队表演的最后一次。所以当丹尼和斯坦出来进行他们最后的掘墓人表演时，那些伊丽莎白时代的笑话不知怎么地奏效了。
Art a heathen? How does thou understand the scripture? The scripture said Adam digged. Could he dig without arms?
你是异教徒吗？你是怎么理解经文的？经文说亚当在挖掘。没有手臂他能挖吗？
[AUDIENCE CHUCKLING]
[观众笑声]
Having seen every performance, I can testify, the actors rose above their talents in that last show. Mike and Hudson as the belligerent priests, Buck and Tommy as the ambassadors, Sylvester's Fortinbras. You could feel the mutual support. Just as missed lines and other mistakes play off one another, and can spiral downward into fiasco, the rhythm of the room can go the other way too. Strong lines beget better performances. The gang of Hamlets came together in a way they hadn't before. That little mob seemed like one voice. But the real surprise for me that last night was Hutch.
看过每一场演出，我可以证明，演员们在最后一场演出中超越了他们的天赋。迈克和哈德森饰演好战的牧师，巴克和汤米饰演大使，西尔维斯特饰演福丁布拉。你能感受到相互的支持。正如漏掉的台词和其他错误会相互影响，螺旋式下滑成惨败一样，房间的节奏也可以朝另一个方向发展。强有力的台词会带来更好的表演。这群哈姆雷特以一种他们以前没有过的方式团结在一起。那小小的群体似乎成了一个声音。但那天晚上对我来说真正的惊喜是哈奇。
I am more an antique Roman than a dame. There's still yet some liquor left.
比起女士，我更像是一个古罗马人。这里还有一点酒。
It's here that Hutch's Horatio delivers his most famous line. The play is almost over. He's surrounded by corpses and speaks to his dying friend Hamlet. In the other performances, I always thought Hutch had been plagued by what you might call the Jack Nicholson syndrome. The actor's persona is bigger than any role he might play. But tonight, Horatio has Hutch under control and the audience in his hand. He has the one great line to deliver. And as Hutch might say, he nails it.
就在这里，哈奇饰演的霍拉旭说了他最著名的台词。戏快结束了。他被尸体包围着，对垂死的哈姆雷特说话。在其他演出中，我总觉得哈奇被所谓的“杰克·尼科尔森综合征”所困扰。演员的个人魅力大于他可能扮演的任何角色。但今晚，霍拉旭完全掌控了哈奇，而哈奇也掌控了观众。他有一句伟大的台词要念。正如哈奇所说，他念绝了。
Now cracks a noble heart. Good night, sweet prince, and flights of angels sing thee to thy rest.
现在，一颗高贵的心碎了。晚安，甜美的王子，愿天使的歌声送你安息。
[HORNS]
[号角声]
So Hamlet dies, and Fortinbras takes over. And then the drums of Hamlet's funeral begin. On other stages, a curtain would fall. But here, beneath the cafeteria's unforgiving fluorescence, the actors just stop. From the back of the room, Agnes says simply--
哈姆雷特死了，福丁布拉接管了。然后哈姆雷特葬礼的鼓声响起。在其他舞台上，大幕会落下。但在这里，在食堂那无情的荧光灯下，演员们只是停住了。从房间后面，艾格尼丝简单地说——
End of play.
剧终。
[AUDIENCE APPLAUDING]
[观众掌声]
The audience tonight is a mix of St. Louis' artistic elite. It's a theater crowd-- polite, well-dressed people. Many of them have helped fund this production. They want and fully expect to meet the talent afterwards. And for many of the actors, this moment-- they call it the cast party-- is the most prized. James Word and Edgar Evans mentioned it specifically when I talked to them. Just the chance to stand around in a room full of normal people, drink a Coke, and carry on about the play, the future, the weather, the freedom to chat and mingle, like you were in the lobby of a theater instead of a bulletproof visiting room.
今晚的观众是圣路易斯艺术精英的混合体。这是一个戏剧人群——礼貌、衣着考究的人。他们中的许多人资助了这次演出。他们想要并完全期待之后能见到演员。对许多演员来说，这一刻——他们称之为剧组聚会——是最珍贵的。当我与詹姆斯·沃德和埃德加·埃文斯交谈时，他们特别提到了这一点。只是有机会站在一个充满正常人的房间里，喝杯可乐，聊聊戏、未来、天气、聊天的自由，这就像是在剧院大厅，而不是防弹的探视室。
Hey, how you doing?
嘿，你好吗？
I'm doing well.
我很好。
Good to see you.
很高兴见到你。
This is my sixth time here.
这是我第六次来这儿了。
Yeah, you come to all of them. Yeah, I appreciate it. And we thank you. Thank you very much.
是的，你每次都来。是的，我很感激。我们非常感谢你。非常感谢。
In a high-security prison, though, when a play is over, it's over. No sooner had the bows finished than Danny, who doubles as the stage manager, turns right around and starts frantically striking the set. The guards had informed everyone that they'd have about 10 minutes for the cast party.
在高安全监狱里，然而，当一出戏结束时，它就结束了。鞠躬刚结束，担任舞台经理的丹尼立刻转身，开始疯狂地拆卸布景。警卫通知大家，剧组聚会大约有10分钟时间。
Like any play, all the work was for this moment-- to get to the end of the last performance successfully. And now that it's here, these few minutes are shot through with a kind of melancholy. Soon everything will end, and everyone will return to his pre-acting life. Here, that near future is visible. In the side room, everyone sees him, is the guard waiting to strip search them back into the yard. He wears a dull expression on his face and rubber gloves on his hands. But that would be 10 minutes from now. There's still time for pretending.
像任何演出一样，所有的努力都是为了这一刻——成功地走到最后一场演出的结尾。现在它到了，这短短的几分钟里透着一种忧郁。很快一切都会结束，每个人都会回到他排练前的生活中去。在这里，那种即将到来的未来是清晰可见的。在侧室，每个人都能看到那个守卫，正等着给他们搜身，把他们送回院子里去。他脸上的表情呆滞，手上戴着橡胶手套。但这将是10分钟后的事。现在还有装模作样的时间。
Thank you, sir. Thanks for coming out. We appreciate the support.
谢谢你，先生。谢谢你来观看。我们感谢你们的支持。
I really like this act. I like the--
我真的很喜欢这一幕。我喜欢——
It was so complicated.
它太复杂了。
--counter-balance between the beginning and the end.
——开始和结尾之间的平衡。
According to the prison commissioner, 97% of the people locked up today will someday join us on the outside. Manuel is leaving for a halfway house in 48 hours. He could have been out weeks before but chose to stay in prison so he could finish the play. Hutch has a scheduled date for release. And a few more of the cast have parole board hearings coming up to decide whether they've changed enough and should be allowed to mingle with us on the outside. To that extent, this whole night, including the cast party, is just another rehearsal.
据监狱专员称，今天被关押的人中有97%的人将来会加入我们的社会。曼努埃尔将在48小时内离开监狱前往中途之家。他本可以在几周前就出去了，但选择留在监狱，以便完成这部戏。哈奇有预定的释放日期。还有几位演员有假释委员会的听证会，决定他们是否已经改变了足够多，应该被允许与我们这些外人来往。在某种程度上，整个夜晚，包括剧组聚会，都只是又一场排练。
Thanks for coming!
谢谢你们的到来！
Oh, you were great.
哦，你们太棒了。
Thank you. I'm glad you enjoyed it.
谢谢。很高兴你们喜欢。
So, you think you like performing?
所以，你觉得你喜欢表演吗？
Yes, ma'am.
是的，女士。
Well, you're very good.
嗯，你演得很好。
Jack Hitt, he's a longtime contributor to our show and a writer for the New York Times Magazine.
杰克·希特，他是我们节目的长期贡献者，也是《纽约时报杂志》的撰稿人。
Since we first aired this program back in 2002, all of the main actors that Jack to in his story have been released from prison. Edgar, who played Claudius, went to work at a hospital - became chief union steward there - and recently retired. Big Hutch works in public transit. Tim moved to Hollywood hoping to produce his own screenplays. Danny, the guy who talked about speaking as the man he killed -- was released from prison just a few months ago, in May. Manuel got out long ago and died in a truck crash in 2008.
自从我们2002年首次播出这期节目以来，杰克报道故事中的所有主要演员都已出狱。饰演克劳狄斯的埃德加去了一家医院工作，成为那里的工会主管，最近退休了。大哈奇在公共交通部门工作。蒂姆搬到了好莱坞，希望能制作自己的剧本。丹尼，那个谈论着以他杀掉的人的角度说话的家伙——几个月前，即五月份刚出狱。曼努埃尔很久以前就出去了，但在2008年死于一场卡车事故。
Agnes Wilcox their director died in 2017 after decades of running Prison Performing Arts, which she founded. Chris, Edgar, and Big Hutch were at her funeral. The organization is still going strong. Chris Edgar and Brat are involved with their alumni theater program. You can learn more about them at prisonperformingarts.org.
他们的导演艾格尼丝·威尔科克斯在经营了她创立的“监狱表演艺术”几十年后，于2017年去世。克里斯、埃德加和大哈奇参加了她的葬礼。该组织仍在强劲发展。克里斯、埃德加和布拉特参与了他们的校友戏剧项目。你可以在prisonperformingarts.org了解更多关于他们的信息。
[MUSIC - "DESPERADO"]
[音乐 - "亡命之徒"]
This episode of our program was produced by Alex Blumberg, with Starlee Kine, Wendy Dorr, Jonathan Goldstein, and me. Our senior producer for this episode was Julie Snyder. Our technical director for our show is Matt Tierney. Production help with today's show from Diane Wu.
本期节目由亚历克斯·布伦伯格制作，参与人员包括斯塔莉·基恩、温迪·多尔、乔纳森·戈尔茨坦，还有我。本期节目的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。我们节目的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼。今天节目的制作帮助来自黛安·吴。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our programs co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia, or as we like to call him, Shamu.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX传送给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生，或者我们喜欢称呼他为“夏穆”。
I control the killer whales. And I can eat up them minnows if I want.
我控制虎鲸。如果我想，我可以吃掉小鱼。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。